foreign  [Music]  [Music]  bud  does this thing work yes  up we go  perfect  [Music]  okay so he's fixing is floating here  just popping this pipe we're on our way  the only way to fly man  oh wow  oh here we are Palace doors  [Music]  [Music]  oh my God okay  not sure if you know who I am but I'm  about to rule the world wow  yay but there's one problem there's a  human has a mustache just like you  do you think I know every human being  with a mustache wearing an identical  outfit with a hat with the letter of his  first name on it because I don't  Bowser is coming  together we  are going to stop that monster how look  at us we're horrible oh I got this no  problem  get it out get it out get it off  there's a huge Universe out there  there's a lot of galaxies  they're all counting on us  wahoo  [Music]  [Music]